Stacy wants to find the derivative of f
of X equals x squared plus 1 at the
point x equals 2 her table below shows
the average rate of change of F over the
intervals at from X to 2 or from 2 to X
and these are closed intervals for X
values they get increasingly closer to 2
so they get so we're talking about the
average rate of change of F over these
closed intervals for X values that get
increasingly closer to 2 it looks like
we're going to be dealing with some type
of a limit or we're trying to calculate
some type of a limit or approximate some
type of a limit so let's read this data
here so these are the x values and she's
trying to find the average rate of
change between each of these X values
and 2 or the average rate of change of
the function when between what X is he
one of one of these X values and two and
then she has the average rate of change
that she pre calculated so we don't have
to get a calculator out or anything like
that and just as a reminder how did she
calculate this 3.9 well they tell us she
took f of 1.9
what is the function equal when X is 1.9
from that she subtracted what is the
value of the function when F is equal to
2 so that's really our change in F and
she divided it by the X which is one
point nine minus two so change in f over
change in X so what is the average rate
of change of our function over that
interval and so she did it between 1.9
and two she got three point nine then
she gets closer to two so now she's
doing it between one point nine nine and
two and it becomes three point nine nine
it looks like it's getting closer to
four she gets even closer to two and the
average rate of change gets even closer
to four and then she goes on the other
side of two you could view it as this is
approaching this is this is approaching
this is X approaching 2 from the left
hand side and this is X approaching 2
from the right hand side so when it's
two point one the average rate of change
is four point one what is 2.01 once
again we're getting closer to two
we're getting closer to the average rate
of change is getting closer to four the
closer we get to two the closer the
average rate of change gets to four so
what this data is really helping us
approximate it's really saying OK the
average rate of change we know is f of X
minus f of 2 over X minus 2 but what
we're really thinking about is well what
is the limit as X approaches 2 right
over here that's what this data is
helping us to get at and it looks like
this limit is equal to 4 they give us
the data here it says look The Closer
that X gets to 2 from either the
left-hand side or the right-hand side
The Closer that this expression right
over here which is this number gets to 4
and you might recognize this is one of
the definitions of a derivative this is
the one of the definitions of a
derivative this right over here would be
F prime of 2 the derivative at x equals
2 is equal to the limit as X approaches
2 of all of this business there's other
ways to express the derivative as a
limit but this is one of them and so
there you go from the table what does
the derivative of f of X equals x
squared plus 1 at X equal to appear to
be well the derivative at x equals 2
appears to be equal to 4 and we're done